google's alphago shocked the world by
defeating go legend Lisa Dole yesterday
this upset wasn't a fluke the AI program
developed by google's deepmind unit has
just won the second game of a five-game
go match but now what we're seeing is
that for the first time computers can
see as well as humans that's pretty
incredible if you combine that with the
ability to have arm like nip y elation
then they can make us far more
productive but then you know the job
market has to adjust to that I think we
should be very careful about artificial
intelligence if I regret at what our
biggest existential threat is it's
probably that but development of
artificial intelligence could spell the
end of the human race and a guy I've got
a theory the first super intelligence
will be a human machine hybrid
[Music]
so on this channel I'm interested in
anything that can potentially improve
human performance so that includes all
the stuffs can do right now to that
fitness training brain training
nootropics etc productivity tip it also
includes transhumanism potential future
technologies that could someday create
genuine superhumans I find that
completely fascinating I don't know why
anyone wouldn't so with that in mind I
read occasional science fiction and a
very popular topic in science fiction is
something called the singularity it's
also a popular topic in science in
general so the singularity is a point in
the future at which the rate of
technological acceleration is going to
become self-sustaining it's going to
gain so much momentum that we're having
all these breakthroughs and it's each
breakthroughs leading to more
breakthroughs and just the world is
changing it's such an incredible rate
that we can't even imagine it you know
as in store the line between technology
and magic has become blurred it's often
suggested that this will be the result
of an artificial intelligence in AI that
will basically be able to solve all our
problems for us so we create an
intelligence a computer program that
intelligence becomes so intelligent that
it's able to make all these scientific
breakthroughs even improve its own
artificial intelligence this accelerates
an increasing rate and the world
completely changes this is the
futuristic utopia that many scientists
dreams of but also many people obviously
quite scared of because it could result
in a Terminator or matrix type scenario
but the argument I'm making is that this
isn't going to happen we might reach the
singularity but it won't be in
artificial intelligence in my opinion
that is responsible I think something
much more interesting but we work
wantable a topic that you hear about a
lot less interesting and that is
probably just around the corner arguably
even here right now
that's an EXO cortex so this is
something a bit different I don't always
talk about these kind of topics on the
channel but I made a video on working
memory recently and something on virtual
reality and brain training just to test
the waters to see if you guys like this
kind of content and although they've got
fewer views they did get a lot of
engagement and people responding and
chipping in so I thought I'd do another
one similar let me know
comments below if you find this
interesting if you'd like me to stick to
bodybuilding and that and shut up about
the singularity let's start by looking
at where artificial intelligence is
right now the topic that is very
relevant to transhumanism to
self-improvement in the future and it's
certainly something that I think you'll
find interesting if you stick with me
so as you know artificial intelligence
is everywhere right now it's massive
news it's in your phone it's in your car
you've got self-driving cars you've got
silly you've got Google Assistant you've
got all kinds of tools that rely on some
amount of artificial intelligence the
enemies in your computer games their
artificial intelligence but whilst these
things are incredible they're not
actually as incredible as someone who
wants the singularity to happen might
hope because these examples of narrow
artificial intelligence or weak AI
sometimes called reactive AI basically
these are a is that response to our
command or our actions or they respond
to events in the world around them they
can't think they can't plan they don't
have consciousness of any kind they are
literally there to serve one purpose and
it's not even that they can do all kinds
of things like a robot they just perform
one purpose so Google assistant helps
you search for things and handle your
phone the AI in a computer game will
respond to your attacks and all of this
is essentially carried out by a kind of
flow diagrams so you perform one action
and something else happens and the
program says if X and y happens then du
said if a and B happens then do C so
there's no real thought process is not
in some ways it's not an intelligence at
all it's just an illusion of an
intelligence it's really just like I say
a large
flowchart that results in some kind of
response your inputs without this input
it can do nothing so this is come on a
long way thanks in part to machine
learning machine learning is a very
interesting topic as well but it's also
not a form of intelligence that's going
to take over the world or create a
supercomputer I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
machine learning is essentially data
analysis and pattern recognition so
machine learning means you're connecting
huge data set
called Big Data awesome that's the
buzzword right now and this data is then
used to look for patterns that allow
machines to work in smarter ways so for
instance voice recognition machine
learning allows voice recognition to
work by looking at those modes and loads
of examples of people talking giving the
response if you get the hit then it
reinforces that that particular pattern
of sounds means X if it doesn't get a
hit then it discards it likewise face
recognition software works in a similar
way machine learning can be used to give
you suggestions on Spotify on Amazon
those are examples of artificial
intelligence though quite rudimentary so
yeah machine learning also fascinating
and certainly will result in
breakthroughs in science technology
machine learning could very likely be
used to diagnose illness to see signs of
cancer and things sooner than a human I
could and of course a machine is capable
of going through much greater data sets
than a human would be and especially
want to use cloud computing to pull the
resources of multiple machines into one
system so I'm not saying it's not
amazing I'm not saying it's not going to
create lots of breakthroughs however it
is not an example of an intelligence
that's going to change the world or go
rogue or do any of the things that
happen they're cool in films about
robots
learning a slightly more interesting
type of intelligence is something called
general AI and general AI is essentially
the kind of intelligence that is
designed to replace the intelligence of
a human so this is the intelligence that
seen in the TV series humans before they
gained consciousness it's also what
you'd ideally like something like Siri
to be able to do it's an intelligence
that can pass the Turing test and it can
learn to do multiple different things so
if you to speak to an MSN program but
with a general AI and it was a really
good one you and get a tell if it was
human or if it was a robot
likewise generally I could be used to
cook you dinner and then lower your baby
to sleep and then give you a massage and
play with Sonic the Hedgehog in other
words like I say you can do everything
that human can do but it's still
potentially a program series of events
or basically a flowchart no
consciousness to another life it's a
it's just a much better version of AIS
and we have right now so the best
example of a general AI that we have
right
now is deepmind owned by google now and
deep mind uses a kind of phone neural
network to spot patterns but be able to
respond to things in a non
pre-programmed way and learn in the
similar manner to a human it's got a
kind of basic short-term memory and
essentially in theory it should be able
to answer your questions and try and
pass the Turing test although you
probably will be able to spot the
difference and it can also answer a
range of different questions and
potentially learn different things
that's been used in medicine etc just
pretty cool but it's still a long way
off of being you know like Arnold
Schwarzenegger in terminators - so how
does consciousness arise how do you get
a living mind well that's the problem we
don't know we don't have a model for how
consciousness works in the human brain
and thus how can we possibly make
something that works like that in a
computer these learning algorithms they
use the system that similar to
behavioral psychology behavioral
psychology says that we learned
everything through trial and error and
positive reinforcement and negative
reinforcement so the idea is that you
start off as a prank blank slate and you
learn everything that it is to be you
via interactions with the world so you
learn as an infant that you can reach
for something your mum will pass it to
you this is the basics of communication
and then you might learn that if you
lean too far to the left B fall over and
you learn how to stand up and then you
layer these experiences on top of each
other to become a fully functional human
being and that's how something like
these mind would work with its neural
networks and it's reinforced to learning
however we now know that that isn't all
that there is to being human if you look
at cognitive psychology which is a more
modern school of psychology we know that
is very important you have an internal
model for yourself that you have an
internal dialogue that you're self-aware
these are the things that it means to be
human and of course so I could say
consciousness which is a completely
unquantifiable consideration so how can
you possibly create a computer that's
aware of itself and it's able to make
free choices because to me my personal
interpretation of consciousness is the
ability to make an unpredictable choice
to be self-aware and not only aware but
able to act on that basis from wherever
not from an algorithm not from
charter from whatever it is that makes
us human and as we don't know what that
is how can we possibly make an
artificial intelligence that will do
that there are people who think I'm
wrong and they're much much smarter than
me much more than knowledge about and I
suspect that they know of technologies
that I'm not aware of so Elon Musk
thinks that our special intelligence is
going to be the downfall of man it's
terribly dangerous even Hawking also
signed a petition saying that AI was
very dangerous and we need regulatory
regulations in order to make sure it
doesn't run away from us and then take
over us and enslave us in units of human
batteries which is unlikely because
humans are very inefficient energy
sources that has been pointed out many
times in the past the point is there
might be something I'm not aware of but
based on what we are aware of it doesn't
allow about anywhere near to creating a
consciousness I just want to quickly
point out that artificial intelligence
wouldn't have to become sentient through
it to pose some kind of threat AI and
machine learning could be put to
malicious ends they could be used in a
propaganda war they could be used to
create financial crashes etc and if
these kinds of threats that many expert
minds warning against not necessarily
the idea that we're going to have a
terminator to situation on our hands the
only way I can think we would create the
consciousness and the only Theory from
psychology that I think has any
relevance is the idea that consciousness
is an emergent property of the brain
that is to say that when you create
human brain or life consciousness is a
kind of byproduct of all the thought
process that goes on so you don't have
to create consciousness you create an
intelligence and it becomes conscious of
course that's a cop-out answer it's just
basically we don't know what it is it
just kind of happens but that doesn't
mean that we can't still try and
replicate that and use it as a useful
tool for building and intelligence so we
could create a kind of intelligence and
and hope that it becomes consciousness
and the way I think we would do that is
actually to virtual reality so to
demonstrate how this might work
consider Conway's game called life it's
called the game of life sometimes that
actually it's just called life this
actually started life as a board game
but it's now been
there's multiple computer simulations so
in this game the idea is that you have a
grid and on that grid you have certain
rules that each grid will start off with
a certain number of cells on it which
are just filled in squares on the grid
if there's a certain number of neighbors
to that Square then it dies this is a
different number of neighbors to an
empty square then a new cell emerges
it's just a basic symbol of just a basic
selection rule I mean each turn you kill
the cells that need to die based on
those rules and you create new ones
where there's the correct number of
neighbors but what's interesting about
this is over a huge grid and thousands
upon thousands of terms all sorts of
strange behaviors start to emerge there
are different kind of organisms that
bring to life from these basic rules
things called like floaters and other
things and they move across the board
they reproduce they fire projectiles
they survive multiple ghosts infinite
goes because they've created these
optimal shapes and until they collide
with something else they stay that way
and people who can either use these same
rules in order to create much more
complex systems like calculators and now
imagine you have a literally infinite
grid or a near infinite grid taking
infinite or near infinite number of
terms probability alone means that the
calculator and possibly far more complex
systems would emerge over time and those
that survive would stay and would
reproduce due to the same laws of
evolution that govern our evolution so
in theory he was to say that this
wouldn't eventually create likes I mean
that's very far-fetched it's very
strange but I mean I think that's a
better way of potentially coming up with
a conscious AI even just trying to
figure out how the program consciousness
because I don't think it's that simple
and in a much more advanced system like
a proper virtual reality you could
create a far more demanding set of
circumstances you could even simulate
our own evolutionary circumstances and
in hopes that life would emerge and then
what's even more interesting is that you
could then reverse engineer the code
that represented that life and you could
use that reverse engineering to then
understand how conch
this does work and this is actually one
of the concepts in Tron to which
everyone thinks is a goofy colorful film
but actually that's a pretty deep
subject so I've always liked it the Daft
Punk music is great and actually makes
sense that you would need a kind of
virtual reality in order for life to
emerge if you've seen my video read my
post on embodied cognition then you'll
know that another very popular theory in
psychology is that our conscious thought
requires interaction with a physical
world in order to emerge there's to say
that we only understand things because
we can relate them back to the context
of the reality that we live in so that
sounds incredibly complicated I suggest
you watch that video because I'm going
to go over it quickly here but the point
is to summarize when someone talks to
you and tells you a story we used to
think that that would be translated to a
kind of language of the brain called
mental ease what we now know is that
instead the brain uses visualization to
imagine itself in that context when
someone tells you about themselves
walking through the cold woods you
picture yourself in the cold woods and
we only understand that because we
understand numbers from our interactions
of the world around us so as you can see
you need to have an experience with a
physical world in order to have an
internal monologue and an understanding
of what's being said to you without
being if your disembodied intelligence
you've got no context you've got no
reason to live you've got no motivation
devolution can't happen you can't
understand anything that's happening
because you've got no basis of reference
but if you're alive even in a virtual
world then you can start to learn things
and there's companies like improbable
that are working on these highly complex
cloud computing powered simulations of
reality where such a thing could
actually occur it has the raw processing
power and the detail to allow embodied
cognition to do its thing in an emergent
AI potentially quite a big claim I'm
making there quite a out-there theory
for a guy who just read a wide article
but that's what I think and I think it's
fairly interesting and of course there's
the theory that some prominent thinkers
have including once again Elon Musk that
we might be living in a virtual reality
right now but we might
the product of such an experiment and in
fact the argument goes that there are so
many possible virtual realities that can
emerge from a single actual reality that
statistically we're more likely to be in
a VR than we are in an actual reality of
based reality if such a thing even
exists so in other words if you've got
one real universe that can create a
million virtual realities then
statistically it more like to be in one
of the million virtual realities the
idea about the virtual realities and us
being in one was put forward by Nick
Bostrom and the technology that the
company improbable is working on is
called spatial OS in case you want to do
more research and just to quote the
correct references so hopefully found
that all very interesting
I certainly do but my ultimate
conclusion is that we're not going to
create a conscious AI capable of
bringing about the singularity anytime
soon the best way to do it is certainly
a bit of a gamble and a shot in the dark
so what I think is much more likely is
that an exit cortex will be the first
super intelligence and the thing to
bring about the singularity so an XO
cortex is literally an external cortex
it's a piece of machinery that enhances
the function of your brain just like an
exosuit gives you extra strength and
exit cortex gives you extra brain power
but it's a piece of software and/or
hardware it's not something you hear
about very often at all and in fact the
only example I can think of some fiction
is the helmet that Charles Xavier wears
when he's trying to enhance his
telekinetic powers someone remind me of
the name of that in the comments below
if you've watched this far so the idea
is that rather than relying on an
artificial intelligence to come up with
all these breakthroughs and to increase
its own intelligence we instead upgrade
their own minds using technology we
provide the peak consciousness it
provides the machine learning and
therefore we become geniuses so the next
cortex possible well obviously we don't
know for sure but we've had a lot of
breakthroughs and there's a lot of
research and technological development
that suggests we're certainly on the
right track
we can already interpret what's going on
inside the brain by looking at
activation of specific neurons and by
purposefully stimulating neurons using
electrodes we can create an input to do
all sorts of different things
one of the coolest examples of this is a
piece of research where they managed to
recreate what someone was seeing by
looking at activity in their visual
cortex so they showed the participant a
video of something and then they watched
what was happening in their brains the
occipital lobe the visual cortex is at
the back of the head and then using that
they created blurry recreations what
they saw on the screen it was hard to
make out wasn't perfect by means low
spatial and temporal resolution but the
point is that you were close to being
able to see what these people thought
and using that same technology in theory
you'd be able to see what people are
seeing in their dreams or even in their
imagination so it wouldn't be that hard
like I mean it is hard but it wouldn't
take that many extra steps for a
potentially have a computer that could
read what you were thinking and then
provide you with the information you
needed before you even thought to do it
there are also technologies that allow
paralyzed patients to move a mouse
around the screen and there's
technologies that help to restore
people's vision by stimulating the
visual cortex with electrodes implanted
and thus they have this kind of like
Gameboy type vision much lower
resolution more like Virtual Boy nerdy
Jake they're more like Virtual Boy so
they could see you know the world around
them in a very low resolution with these
kind of big red pixels but the point is
that eventually you've got an input and
an output there so you could have a
computer that does all the processing
power cloud computing machine learning
you think man I need to know the name of
that song and your computer's just
automatically sends it to your brain and
you can play it in your head
imagine a virtual reality where you can
actually walk around because all of your
senses are stimulated just as though it
was the real reality imagine knowing
everything that's on the web as though
it was already in your head imagine
being able to spot incredible patterns
and the data coming into your eyes
imagine being able to store all of your
memories your working memories your
long-term memories relive them
perfectly imagine being able to juggle
hundreds of numbers in your mind without
getting any of them swimming around all
this data I mean that's possible it's
not too many steps away I personally
think it's a long long time before
people accept having a implant of any
sort inserted into their brain so I
think it's more likely a one-way thing
where it picks up on information from
your brain using a kind of transcranial
solution and then provide you with the
information in front of you on the
screen so that you can just retrieve
information to store ideas etc so I
think that the people who would use an
implant could potentially think in whole
new ways especially when you combine
this with brain plasticity our brains
ability to adapt and change shape in
response to novel stimuli and we've seen
that if you give a monkey a new robotic
arm its brain changes shape in order to
deal with that new arm so that it
becomes as though as part of their body
always in other words your brain will
change shape to adapt to the new
information coming in and your new way
of using it so my point is that while an
AI is a long way off we could
potentially enhance our intelligence
with a kind of XO cortex to a massive
degree and this is already precedented
you no word any computer program is
already a form of XO cortex and abacus
with a form of extra cortex of pen and
paper is a form of XO cortex whereas our
AIS dating back that far automata best
far more rudimentary the point is that
I'm trying to make an ex cortex is
further along it's less of a jump than a
you know omnipotent omniscient AI so I
think that the first super intelligence
will be a human machine hybrid yeah that
we found that interesting guys likes a
really different really long but I just
thought I'd give it a try
I've got all the usual stuffs come in
here soon
including Bruce Lee's diet how to
concentrate and focus more productivity
tips etc explosives workout routine
all the usual stuff and if you want to
see more of this kind of thing - then
I've got more of that as well so let me
know and thanks so much for watching so
much for subscribing so much for
commenting and follow me on social media
really appreciated that having a blast
of this channel and yeah I'll see you
the next one so thanks again and bye for
now
[Music]